you you know very much identified as a
feminist and there's all that stuff
harriet hart person and all that i mean
do you feel we're over that now that
that that actually it's not an issue
anymore and perhaps it was when you
started well i think that there's a lot
more of an understanding of what the
argument is however a lot of the issues
still remain to be dealt with
but
women are a critical mass now in
politics so we are not
you know the rare isolated outsider
the government saying that those
hospitals which opt out are still part
of the health service will still provide
basic treatment to everybody
opted out hospitals will only have to
provide accident emergency treatment and
core services
in that clip that we've just looked at
let's see
sky news's first bulletin
i think that you can tell that
i am
hoping that people will be listening and
hoping that they will i'm always
was trying to persuade in a rather
deferential way not necessarily
believing that people were going to be
paying any attention it's a bit
deferential now i feel like telling my
younger self to get a grip and speak a
bit more authoritatively
you got criticized for your dungarees or
something didn't you at one point um
i
i mean
the amount of time
that
that we all thought about
what on earth we should wear in the
chamber
and as politicians out and about you
know it was quite easy for a man to be
in a suit but there was no such thing as
a professional woman's clothing because
there virtually were hardly any
professional women
i wanted to look like i could convey
to my constituents and people that i was
somebody who could help them if they
needed help and was authoritative
the results are still coming in but one
of the things that i found most
heartening
is the new labour women members of
parliament that are coming in from the
marginals
and you don't think over the decades
it's got crueler you think it's pretty
much the same oh i think it's pretty
much the same i think it's
yeah i think it's it's always been there
i mean i i feel less so about it now but
i remember
feeling always
under threat in a way of somehow
something would be exposed about me that
i would have
done i couldn't think what it might be
but that i would be found out for having
done something terrible and vilified
across the press and always that feeling
of jeopardy camera the cameras are not
there off camera okay
the press gave me as a politician a
feeling of constant jeopardy that i just
lived with